Bây giờ, sau hội tục tiên ngà Mỹ tại Alaska, em sau tất tắng, tổng thống đất đi mì pu chiến nhấn mạnh,
của gặp với tổng thống mình đường tròm sĩnh phát đúng thế giới.
Và mang tính xây dân ông lạnh giá hội nghĩ đến giả thận tháng và trí rử tụng tiên,
đồng thời tiên tưởng rằng sự gặp này đã xuống ngà tiến gần hơn tới Việt tiên giá các sẽ phát tình thiết,
trên những vấn đề của tế đặc biệt là xung đồ của khuy nào.
Tổng thống pu tiên trò rằng việc loại bỏ các ngoài nhìn gốc dễ của xung đồ,
cần được calla lên tàng cho bất kỳ thật nào trong tương ai, ông cũng thử nhận.
Ngà lông này thiếu vàng các cố đối thoại trực kế bởi gấp cơm nhất,
vào hội y Alaska đã mở ra cơ hội để mắt các bạn thấy lập trường một cách bình tính chi tiết.
Còn ngày, ngoài trường ngà sẽ đề là bước đặt có các cố địa đàn với những người đồng cấp thu nghĩ kỳ và hôm gà rì.
Nhanh chào đổi kết quả hội nhỉ.
Đồng thời thì tục thảo luận trên vọng giải quyết xung đồn ngà của khuy nào.